ah sacré micmac second confinement on
ferme les commerces jugés non essentiels
par le gouvernement mais pas les grandes
surfaces puis on se rend compte que dans
les grandes surfaces il y à des produits
l'un essentiel joué
habile livres cd dvd et bien d'autres du
coup on les empêche finalement de vendre
les produits en question
dernier épisode en date la grande
distribution doit aussi renoncer aux as
cannes collecte
c'est à dire les commandes effectuées
sur ces articles dont les rayons sont
donc déjà interdit au libre service
on passera sur la communication du
gouvernement un peu bancal ce n'est pas
notre genre d' être médisant d'un autre
côté il y en a un qui se frotte les
mains c'est jeff bezos ce qui doit être
le seul à qui fait son années 2020 sur
le 3ème trimestre amazon a vu son
chiffre d'affaires augmenter de 37% son
bénéfice triplé dépassant les six
milliards de dollars et prévoit entre
112 et 114 milliards de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires pour le quatrième
trimestre généralement le meilleur de
l'année grâce aux fêtes de noël
le groupe aurait carrément recruté près
de 400000 personnes dans le monde depuis
le début de l'année bref les affaires
vont plutôt bon train alors pour freiner
les ardeurs d'amazon le gouvernement
leur a demandé de supprimer leur
campagne de pub massif sur le pré black
friday
l'opération commerciale d'avant noël à
la fin du mois de novembre
ce qu'ils ont accepté de faire sans
toutefois pour le moment supprimer le
black friday en lui même faut pas
déconner non plus
[Musique]